do you think Travis Kelsey and Taylor
Swift's relationship could be fake yes I
thought Kelsey jerseys up 400 T Swift
pulled up to the game could this be a
plan to boost NFL's popularity to
different audience okay we we uh we
spoke about this on brilliant I think
and I don't know if Taylor is 100 aware
of this I don't know if that because a
lot of times people can do things
without even realizing why they're doing
them you know we're all seduced by Fame
we're seduced by our goals our
aspirations right
so I think it's possible like Travis
Kelsey has been in the in the you know
the public eye for a while not just as a
football player like he had the dating
show obviously like he he wants to be
famous he's into the fashion thing he's
posting his fashion things on Instagram
he he likes being a public figure at
least it appears that that's something
that he enjoys part of his brand
so I'm sure it's seductive to be around
arguably the biggest public figure alive
right now and you see the reaction
you're getting from it which is way
bigger than any dating show you're
already willing to date someone for fame
and now you're dating the girl yeah you
know who makes people famous
so I'm sure that that can be seductive
so I understand where Travis is coming
from it I wonder
if there's any part of Taylor and I said
there's some brilliant idiots I wonder
if there's any part of Taylor Swift
that realizes she's done everything in
music except one thing what is the
highest Mountaintop in music what is the
one thing that Taylor Swift has not
achieved just yet and it is very
difficult for her and her fan base to
achieve but when you do achieve this it
cements you on Mount Rushmore of
musicians what is the one event I've got
to guess what is the guess miles
halftime Super [__] the halftime
show the Super Bowl Halftime the BET
Awards or the bet
so uh yeah honorable mention at the bet
but the halftime show and maybe there's
a part of her that's like oh I really
like this guy he's Charming he's fun
he's a [__] stud right yeah and
here's an audience that doesn't know
about me oh their wives know about me
all their girlfriends know about me
they're all showing up to the show
I'm just starting to have some Crossover
with men it's almost become ironically
cool to go to my show as dudes and
really lean in obviously you saw what I
did he saw a Portnoy there's been a
bunch of other guys there like yo this
is she's you saw uh uh Stephen A Smith
yeah uh saying it was the best show he's
so it's starting to happen she's
entering the Sports World Stephen A
Smith right Portnoy right you see
there's a whole bar stool contingent
built around Swifton makes sense what's
the one show that I haven't done and you
know what I probably won't be able to do
because I'm not big enough in that
demographic I'm seeing all these other
artists that aren't as big as me to it
I'm seeing all these other artists out
there that are headlining the halftime
show that I'm bigger than
I play these stadiums without the
football game yeah nice multiple
multiple night yo how many Super Bowl
games are there one I got six yeah I got
six Super Bowls here's what's crazy now
I guess they scale it down for uh for a
concert but Texas Stadium seats 100 000
cheated Texas stadium or the Cowboy
stadium three times at seventy thousand
the Cowboys will sell out that Stadium
eight times this year she sold it out
three times how nuts
three shows she did that year that's not
the only place she did every city in
America so she she will sell more
tickets this year than any uh football
team yeah all right guys we're gonna
take a break real quick and you know
what this blue lighting means it means
it's time for blue chew Peds performance
enhanced dicks and you know you need one
of them stop bagging like you don't your
dick game ain't that great I heard women
talk y'all ain't [__] in the bedroom but
you don't have to be all you gotta do is
go to Bluetooth and if you go to
bluetooth.com flagrant you get your
first shipment for free ladies your
man's dick ain't [__] even if he's a
good guy let's be honest so what you do
is you go to bluetooth.com flagrant
first shipment is free all you got to do
is pay five dollars for shipping and
handling that's it promo code
flagrantblue2.com flagrant promo code
flagrant first shipment is free now
let's get back to the show the one
pushback I give you
the Super Bowl halftime show I guess
it's a few years ago but they've had
[__] Tom Petty they have military is
huge he's huge but Taylor Swift
this is this is this is a gender thing
not a size Rihanna last year then we
love Rihanna
we love I don't think we love I don't
think the Middle America that really
loves the NFL necessarily loves Rihanna
but now you're talking about uh part
section of America instead of fans of
the music and I think Rihanna crosses
genders more than Taylor Swift yeah I
hear that and now I think Taylor's
Crossing but she could look at this like
hey here's this guy I really like he's a
Charming handsome guy we actually get
along it's fun it's fun to go to the
games it's
also cool to know that she's a woman
with aspirations and goals and ambition
it's also good to know that this could
potentially cross her over into a
demographic that she does not always sit
in
I'm looking at that and I'm going oh wow
does she want that halftime show and I'm
also going
she could have this in one year
in one year easily this year it's Usher
next year they need to go country they
can't do Morgan Wallen because he has
the n-word controversy even though he is
the one that would be the biggest Banger
because I feel like he's fully crossed
over all genres you're so big he's
Nirvana he's huge he has the n-word
controversy he [__] up I think ever
his chance of ever doing the Super Bowl
halftime show yeah because it's just
gonna come out yeah like you know what I
mean they're going to be articles
written about it look at the NFL who's
stopped Kaepernick from ever getting a
job and now letting this guy who said
The end like you know what I mean like
they had Katy Perry do it once right
yeah Katy Perry's massive yeah cat lit
phone new girl no I think Katie's more
crossover Heavies playing into this I
don't think Taylor's ever played next to
sex guys
any female artist that's played into how
beautiful and sexy she is you're gonna
have guys that are going to have casual
interests Britney Spears guys we're all
over that yeah yeah Taylor's been I'm a
girl I'm writing songs about guys that
did harmful things to me so as a dude
you're like well [__] don't be talking
about me in the music I can't relate to
this and but she might have found it
I kind of think I I think your your
theory is probably spot on but I think
maybe trying to get more black people yo
and not pissing off her white fan base
while not they found the day Walker
because yeah Travis Kelsey's a day
Walker yeah every black girl is talking
about Taylor right now they hate Taylor
because she already got Beyonce out of
here and without a problem and now she
took their day Walker do you know what I
mean or is he a night walker Texas
oh that's funny so so but like it is a
move maybe it is
all black people are talking about you
she never dated one dude with swag white
do a swag she dated like rocker guys
that had like like rocker swag or like
actor dudes but never a dude who had
some hip-hop swag but what Taylor on
brilliant idiot said it's like he's kind
of losing his swag now that he's dating
her and I don't think it's just because
he's dating her but it's like cheese nah
he's shifting like the whole look you
know how he's acting he's all on some
goofy [__] with the bands and stuff
that's hate bro like he's not walking
around swagging like he used to that kid
superfit was fired no no not the clothes
I'm talking about how he can like
mustache that's a little bit cop looking
but the beard he can grow that bag ain't
nothing wrong with a mustache bro blue
lives do matter
yo there's a there's a thing that uh kid
super did oh so smart it's so smart I'm
gonna mess up the name of the outfit but
basically the jacket Allen has a woman
on it and it was called the jacket was
called the summer girl yeah or something
like that they changed the name on their
website
to Summer of 99.
1989. it almost looks like the cover and
it kind of looks like the cover so now
the Google search for the jacket is also
matching the Google search for
type in Travis Kelsey jacket and it
comes up 1989. so and all the swifties
are going nuts first of all shout out to
the kids super team for doing that but
this is separate note this is why it's
important
when you set up your business to have
heads of each Revenue stream in your
business and Avenue uh one of the
mistakes a lot of times we make and this
is good for product because we're all
working on everything so it maintains
the quality of the product
but one of the bad things is everybody's
always busy so you don't have a moment
where somebody's only looking at their
one thing which is online sales for
their products and they see that jacket
go up and then they go hmm how can I
drive some of this interest into the
jacket into the Taylor Swift thing
change the name on the product let's go
do that that's what happens you have
singular Focus right and that that
person right there they are made and
broken based on the success of their
revenue streams yeah
so that's something I think that we need
to to look at like who is you do a
version of that with your clips yeah
like when something in the news happens
of something relating to what you made a
joke about back in the day that's like
yeah
yeah because that's in The Ether they're
going for it second [__] life but how
do I get somebody who that's their only
way of thinking about that sector of the
biz like for flagrant if there's
somebody that's just looking over
flagrant it's like
hey I noticed it one of our episodes
four weeks ago tapped into this story
about whatever should we switch the
title and the thumb because people are
now talking about it I'm not even
thinking about four episodes ago yeah we
you're on the road you you're editing
your special you have your business like
remember what I said yesterday exactly
so you but like what if there was
somebody who it wasn't their job to be
on air Talent it wasn't their job to
think of funny interesting things to say
listen to it it was their job to just
make sure that we were getting the best
out of the episode and I think that's
where you really are able to level up
and also when you get busy you get to
lean on those people what I've noticed
with us is when we're busy it's it's
very difficult for us to scale because
we're all working on everything yeah you
know we're all pulled in these different
directions so how do we squeeze four
more hours a week yeah yeah you know
well maybe one of the page drones at
home but that's a great idea maybe maybe
patrons maybe we're expanding guys that
clip was from our patreon episode we
drop a new one every single Friday join
the [__] Army at patreon.com
flagrant new episode every single week